你是高雄人嗎
不是
這邊有高雄人嗎
沒有
然後呢我記得就是因為
2020年就是前陣子剛發生這個
安南安南區的這個爆炸
就是他們的這個化學
可以叫爆炸案
然後我就想要來看看
會不會跟高雄七八有同樣的這個
這個用地震你可以看到這樣的效果
然後這是我用
因為這次測試比較新
應該說它的時間比較新
所以它的測試有兩個
一個是DSMIP跟中期相續的測試
所以我先用DSMIP的資料喝不開
然後可以看到說它有一個很明顯
就是一個爆炸
就是它的音波傳導
可是好像爆炸後的P波好像不是很明顯
然後這是我鎖定在10公里裡面
試過去看出有沒有它的P波
好像也不是特別明顯的
這是用氣象組的資料
CWAS
然後一樣他說
一樣有收到同樣的訊號
一樣就是他有
爆炸的訊號出現
好
那看起來就是高雄氣爆
那一個有明顯的P波
但是臺南那個沒有明顯P波
但是它的那個Sonic Wave
非常明顯
那你覺得是什麼原因
臺南巨寶它是它的表面
畫面畫面超好
它的現場出來拍
就是它全身活動的一個
建築的拼爆
我覺得你接下來可以做一件事情
用地震的訊號去定位這個爆炸的位置
因為你現在的那個音
音爆的那個訊號很明顯
那他應該是來自於不同角度
都有收到
那你腦海中有沒有什麼定位的方法的想法
像高中學的定位方法
主要是用批破S波時間差
時間差然後換算成距離
正陽距
然後你有正陽距
就可以畫很多圈圈
然後再找焦點
但你現在手上的資料
沒有時間差
所以你不知道距離
那你要怎麼樣去定位
對,其實我現在是想要讓你從完全就是沒有參考別人的資料的情況下,自己先思考,如果是你的話,你要怎麼做,但其實這個方法已經是well developed,就是非常很多人都已經有方法,你只要去GVC隨便問一下就有了,對,但是我希望你在還沒有問之前,你自己先想一下,
你有什麼方法可以定位
那除了定位之外
你的定位其實想要知道是四個引數
就是發生的時間
還有它爆炸那個正圓位置的水平
位置跟垂直位置
所以會有四個變數
那你要怎麼樣利用你手上的觀測資料
找到這四個
你先自己想一下
然後再看你要怎麼樣
怎麼樣就是做做看
可能下次可以分享一下
我覺得特別臺南那個應該可以定位定的不錯
然後如果
然後接下來如果這些方法慢慢建立起來之後
我們可能要再去分析一下它的
平埔的波形有什麼特徵
然後去看看它是地面的爆炸跟地下的爆炸
它的波形會有什麼特別的地方
然後我想臺灣好像還有其他的爆炸
可能也可以都可以拿來做一做
然後最後可能就是把所有的這個
爆炸事件跟這些可以整理一下
然後我們再去跟國外的案例比較
然後可以看可以把它彙整起來
然後去投稿
我覺得這個路線就是這樣
那你已經有一個很好的開始
就至少你知道怎麼讀資料
怎麼基本分析怎麼看
你已經有觀測了
你現在觀測已經有了
觀測資料已經有了
就是接下來怎麼樣利用觀測資料
去反推其他的東西
好謝謝
好還有誰
陳伯軒還有張志勇也有做
先看張志勇好了
分析不要分析標準時
然後有一個東西比較有趣
我讀了一篇
KU認為它是
我發現它是三個分量的一個
EHB就是分類組
然後ESB是東西這樣的變化量
然後EHLM就是分類組
我發現它措施的
它有更多的
然後每一項分量的
應該是通常的分類
然後
然後所以我去查了車單位置
它剛好
系方是在領域跟前陣地的這個空空的地
然後這個 k 又是在剛好在它的正的
所以它的
就是這個
南北分量的
二別牆
然後方向性
然後其他就是因為我剛剛下的到
但是他有正確的
好像
建立的時間超過了
所以他就沒有抽到那個資料
所以我都下了下的
車站的資料
我來做一個
然後
這個
這個有一個
這樣來顯然熱線
會推測
它的通常多的
效率
這個
正常平衡
它這樣可能
有另外一個
一樣是
隨時分量的
我查 因為他說
從尼瓦道人也知道
從尼瓦道的垂直分量可以改
因為他就是要從尼瓦道過去
然後他會怕把空氣壓開
加上就是高雄細胞
它是那種先凝聚的
很高濃度的瓦斯氣體
在下垂到管道裡面
然後它是凝聚到很高的密度
然後才可以爆炸
所以它這個氣體這樣往外
它會造成蠻明顯的衝擊波
然後它衝擊波還是有
它會把空氣這樣推過去
所以它這邊擺空間
然後
然後空氣這樣推過去
這一道空氣波上面的
空氣會往上移
然後這道空氣波前面的空氣
會被往上移
然後如果在它下面
就會被往下移
對
會造成是垂直方向移動
嗯
上面它的這個
這條藍色線的速度是0.39
空氣
然後它比白的伸縮快一點
還是另外
就是鬆底膊
買這個比什麼
因為它是罰工價值的
爆彈
它會
它是一個平均
就是因為它生活資料上
它會慢慢的衰減
然後衰減到
一般生活價值
它是在一段時間內
的平均數
它會慢慢衰減下來的
這個平均值
它會被搞出
你的上面那張圖往上面移一點
這個好像有兩個訊號
右邊還有一個比較高頻的
這是衝擊波嗎
這兩個時間沒有對齊
那他同一個站有兩個訊號
前面那個比較像是P波嗎
那後面那個是從深坡的衝擊波
那為什麼同一個站會有兩個波
因為他先後抵達
可能是同一個爆炸源的訊號
但是這個訊號走兩條路
一條走空氣
一條走地底
然後空氣也比較慢
就比較晚到
高頻
好 結束了
謝謝
那我覺得你的
你的頻譜的觀察蠻細膩的
是每個站都可以看到衝擊坡的頻譜嗎
那像譬如說你前面有定那個衝擊坡的
那個395那條線
你應該是至少超過一個點以上
你才會去畫這條嘛
那你是參考哪幾個點去畫這條線
這條斜線
紅色那個可能你要用
頻譜來確認一下
看它有沒有那個特性
因為其實你在綠色那一條的頻譜
你已經看到它有
比較高頻的能量聚集
衝擊波的特性
而且它的能量衰減的形式
也跟P波衰減的形式不同
就是這一張
你看那個P波衰減的形式
比較像是就是逐漸的attenuation下來
然後你的衝擊波
看起來就是瞬間就一下就掉下來
能量就不見了
不過高雄氣爆因為它是很多次的爆炸
所以可能也要確認一下
你這個這個是一個這個souls是隻有一次爆炸還是多次的
這個不曉得怎麼怎麼確認
但是你前面的那張圖有看看到你到前面的P波好像有分兩條線
最前面這裡對下面
在下面在下面就是在就是很多條線並列的那一那個那張圖
對這一張
對你前面有兩條虛線值的
那兩條是P波跟S波
那你這個感覺也蠻容易拿來定位的
要不要試試看
因為你有P波有S波
你可以試試看能不能定位
然後另外就是你剛剛有發現
高雄站在南北向
所以它的振幅特別大
所以其實三軸向的訊號
是可以讓你去找到波的那個方向
對
所以你在想一下
怎麼樣從那個三軸向的訊號
找到每一個站看到波的來的方向
對
那我覺得現在就是
不管你是張志勇還是鄭伯凱
你們兩位做的這個分析
都是從觀測的角度上面去看
訊號跟資料
然後你們都有觀察到P波
然後也有人看到有升波
然後有看到有某個方向的政府比較大
某個方向比較小
然後也有看到平衡上面有不同的差異
這些都是我們在觀測這些資料用的
一些要用到一些特徵跟資料
然後可以從這些來反推
爆炸是什麼樣的爆炸
發生在哪裡的爆炸
然後它發生的時間是什麼時候
然後它是地震還是爆炸
甚至於是這種區別都可以做得到
那我們是從
我們現在都完全從物理的角度去推
推演它比較可能性高的是什麼
我們還沒有把AI拿出來用
那在後面的階段
我們也許可以讓AI加入來做判斷的工作
但但我覺得前期這個對他的物理的特性的瞭解是很重要
如果我們稀哩呼嚕都什麼都不管
全部都用AI
這樣可能會不知道自己在做什麼
所以這應該這邊應該把AI當作是協作跟輔助的角色會比較好
然後還是要用物理的觀念跟想法去主導整個研究
然後我想你們兩位可以繼續
繼續在這方面可以再多發揮一下
然後下個星期可以繼續討論這樣
好那再看一下博軒的
然後等一下也請那個靜佳
靜佳你等一下可以講一下你的
然後還有其他同學你也有
好然後也可以分享一下自己的
那個你說有那個雙重氣爆那個訊號
那你上面那個第二個例子
音報衝擊波到達112.7秒是
是什麼意思
所以這個時間是距離爆炸的時間
這個就是跟你那個起始時間
那再看一下你的
所以這個底下這個是有
你有看到P波
這個
你有把訊號做綠波嗎
所以我去看這個教授
他已經有二到八
這個可以看到就是
二到八
因為這些都是
是要像個
像個文章
我是有出品牌資料去重複
就是我發車站會到在哪一張
我們覺得GNS就只有半個英文
然後有些人寫得沒有很清楚
就是然後時間的單位也不太一樣
然後主要是讓我花一點時間跟AI吵架
因為我GPT又沒了
這個AI吵架
這個應該不用AI去抓啦
就自己自己抓
但是我不知道什麼策戰
我覺得你現在有三個case
那你應該要提出三張圖
就很明顯的把你所有的策戰並列起來
經過綠波之後的所有的波形
能不能看出清楚的P波的
的那個triple time curve
還有深坡的triple time curve
先看到這三張圖
然後接著如果都有的話
就表示你已經很確定
你可以抓得到他的批播
那你再用這個批播到時
回推他的證源發生的位置跟時間
那你現在的網頁提供了很多
什麼到時幾秒幾秒以後
因為那個的相對的點
是你資料的起始時間
他的比較沒有那麼大的意義
所以也許你可以先有一個新聞事件的參考時間
把它當成
那也許你的那個arrival time應該是相對於
那個時間要相對於
然後你也可以再用這些觀測資料回推
它的發生時間再去跟新聞的比對一下
但應該不會差距太遠
才會比較合理這樣
好
謝謝
好下一位同學
林玉成
請分享
還有它的遮瑕膏
所以基本上展示是一樣的
然後第三個是
我看
然後這邊是
剛剛提到的
把全部遮瑕膏放在一起
有看到那個音爆的波抵達嗎?
就是有沒有看到兩段的
先P波
然後再音爆的訊號
那你的那個P波的
P波的速度大概是多快
就是依據你的那個觀測資料
你畫出來的走勢曲線
P波的速度是多少
我看你處理的波形都蠻清楚的
其實可以試著去看
看他的那個走勢曲線
現在看起來
你對那個資料的下載跟處理
還有畫圖都沒有問題
但我們要進一步的找到
這些資料背後的隱含的意義
所以第一個最明顯可以看到
就是批播的速度
所以你先把那個走勢區
對 走勢圖把它畫出來
然後看一下速度是多少
然後跟其他同學對一下
應該不會差太多
然後再來就是
因為每個站都看得到批播
所以試著用批播的到時的記錄
去回推地震發生的時間
那個爆炸發生的時間跟位置
對
就是你做完之後
要想想看合不合理
對
要推測一下
對啊
那就是要想一想
然後你們在做的過程中呢
儘量不要太過依賴AI
就是你要有一個
區別就是什麼樣的工作
交給他去做
然後不要讓他讀導太多
這樣子你才會
在那個軸線上面
你不會迷失
不然你會
太多東西未知的情況下
他講什麼你無從判斷
正確還是錯誤
那還有同學
有做氣爆的
東西嗎
沒
好
那就是
我覺得
就這邊四位同學
志勇跟博凱
還有玉成跟博璇
你們已經有初步做一些東西
然後剛剛我有給一些建議
所以我們下個禮拜就可以繼續
把剛剛的建議的東西再往
下做
然後其他同學還沒有進去這個主題的
也沒關係
我覺得反而你們可以像那個
你們可以做那個地震活動的分析
因為我覺得不可能一個人同時
又做這個又做那個又做那個
就不太可能
所以我們也許可以
在討論另外一個主題的時候
你然後其他的同學可以像靖榮啊
還有那個
靖家已經有題目了
靖榮然後還有陳佑神
你也可以
你們就可以做那個跟地震活動相關的部分
然後現在等一下還有一些時間呢
我會有些時間留給黃靖家
你講一下你的那個code if
然後在你講之前
我先講一下地震活動那個部分要怎麼做
那當然你們四位也可以做
就是你們可以自己調配你們的步調
因為你們可能也許就是看一看
然後又很快就可以做出來
也是可以一起做
那我們來看一下另外一個主題
那我來分享一下畫面
從地震活動度做地震預報
我們有兩個資料來源
一個是GDMS的地震活動目錄
一個是GDMS
然後一個是地震測報中心的網頁
那我們現在先從地震測報中心的網頁來看
這個部分就是那個
那個陳佑生
你會想要分享你自己的專題
還是跟著做
我是說接下來的那個專題討論的時候
你要不要找一個東西做
我沒有我知道你怎麼做
我是說你要不要
你要不要做這個地震活動分析
那我現在
我現在講的這個地震活動分析的部分
就是最主要是你跟林靖榮
你們兩位要做
那其他同學也可以繼續做
沒關係
這樣子比較會有每個人都有自己的
至少有一個主題在往前進
不會來這邊只是旁聽
這樣會比較有參與感
好所以這兩
這個部分你們兩個要
特別要注意聽一下
好
首先就是這個
我們去地震測報中心的網頁
然後
然後找到這個地震活動會診
然後右邊有一個放大鏡的地方
可以讓我們搜尋地震的活動
然後我們可以點這個
顯著有感跟小區域都可以點
我們特別可以
我們先用顯著有感來區別
然後你去看一下最近的
比如說五年內的資料
比如說2021年的1月1號到現在
然後所有的地震活動
我們可以看規模
假設5.0來看就這樣
然後查詢
然後他會給你一個目錄一個list
那這個list總共有309個
然後這邊有它的空間分佈
然後你按這個CSV檔之後
它就可以下載成CSV
那我們要做
要這個答案做什麼呢
我想要讓
我想要知道就是
有沒有哪一個
這些都是規模五以上的編號地震
有沒有哪一段時期
它的間隔時間是特別的長
因為我們的先前的一個假設就是
如果今天就是一段時間都沒有大的地震發生
我就可以猜接下來肯定會有很大
那到底它從那個定量上來看
到底要多久
然後有多大
然後在哪裡
並沒有一個系統性的科學性的分析
所以我們透過這樣的搜尋資料
第一個要問的問題就是
每一個地震跟地震之間的間隔時間
到底多長
然後你就可以知道
可能這一個地震跟下一個地震
間隔一天兩天
然後有的間隔十天一個月
然後你就會有一個
有一個概念
然後你就去看一下這個間隔時間
特別長的地震都是
發生在什麼地方
然後它們之間有沒有空間上的關聯性
對 不過我們現在
先從存地震
活動的角度來看
那未來我們可以把GNSS資料加入
因為特別是我們前陣子
你們有去聽那個地震活動報告
地震策劃中心的報告裡面有發現
7月8月的GNSS的資料有異常
就是跟以前的比起來
它的那個擠壓的量特別大
然後有些地方不應該
好像是不應該有什麼偏轉
然後又跟以前的活動的那個pattern
完全不一樣
然後我們就覺得
應該有什麼事情
可能正在醞釀中
但後來的確有發生一個比較大的
但是我覺得那可能還不夠大
因為那個看起來不像是
真的那個異常
應該反映出來的地震
所以我覺得
因為今天是那個
剛好就是你們的下一次的報告
我今天上課我沒有參加
所以我不曉得他們
他們今天的資料有沒有繼續告訴我們
那個異常還在 還是消失
但是他不是那種很大
對 所以我才說那個地震沒有反映出這個異常
感覺關聯性還沒有很強
所以那個異常應該 我個人認為應該還在
而且還沒有 真正expect的那個event沒有出現
還沒有出現
然後如果說它的GPS
GNSS的訊號的pattern還存在的話
那應該還沒有解除
要看今天的報告才知道
但我們現在先從
純地震活動的角度來看
所以你們兩位同學
第一件要做的事情就是
你去看間隔時間多長
每個event跟event之間的間隔時間
但你不一定要用規模五
你也可以規模三
或者是所有的地震都可以
但是我們的背後的想法就是
我們想要知道
如果間隔時間太長
沒有一個顯著地震的話
我們心中想象的是
我的假設是
應該會有一個大的地震
那究竟這個能不能建立一個模型
讓我們當這個模型建立之後
我可以用這個模型去預測未來的地震活動的走向
那就會變得有意義
那模型當然是來自於過去的觀測資料的結果來建立的
那這個模型的功能跟目的就是
如果很久沒有地震
那多久以後會有地震
會有多大
那進一步問可能在哪裡
如果你可以給我一個模型告訴我
就是現在的地震活動的這個pattern
輸入進去
然後你就可以跟我說
可能未來五天內發生規模六以上的地震
機率非常高
而且可能在哪裡特別高
如果你的模型可以告訴我這件事情
那就
對 就會有很有意義
但是我們不可能
我相信我們的模型不可能直接告訴你
那就是有那麼大地震
就是在那裡
就是在那一天那個時候
我們模型應該沒有辦法做到這個
但是現在
這是一個模型通常提供的是機率
就是發生的機率有多高
如果你告訴我是八成
跟告訴我是三成四成
那個意義也不一樣
就是用降雨的機率
那個概念去想它
如果地震也可以發展一個模型
是可以做機率式的預報
而且是完全基於這個地震活動而來的
那應該
該會有一些應用
那我覺得第一步
因為我們的那個理論基礎就在於
很久沒發生
就會發生一個大的
我們的那個中心的假設是這個
所以我們從觀測資料要去看的特徵
就是到底這一次跟下一次間隔多久
然後它之間有沒有什麼關聯性
我記得這個好像有相關的paper跟研究有做過
我好像有看過
就是他們還用一個叫什麼normal distribution
還是Gaussian model
去對這個間隔時間做modeling
就是如果說每個地震
跟每個地震中間發生的時間有長有短
然後你把近十年來的這個有長有短的發生時間
全部plot起來
然後畫一個那個機率
畫一個長條圖
就是比如說間隔一天的有幾次
間隔兩天有幾次
然後三天有幾次
這樣然後累積
然後畫出來
它Expect是成一箇中型分佈
如果它是真的成中型分佈的話
那這個Model就很簡單
就是Normal Distribution
然後用這個Model就可以Predict
未來的事情
因為如果你看到類似的情況
你就可以用model去predict
那如果他不是
那他應該要用什麼model來描述他
或者說以前人做的
可能比較偏時間性的預測
有沒有辦法在空間上告訴我
哪邊機率會比較高
這個我是沒看過
所以這個專題的切入點就是這樣
然後資料非常好取得
就這樣隨便按一下就有了
對
那我們就先不看小的
我們都先看大的
所以也很簡單
那就是你有想法
然後把那個問題描述一下
所以下個禮拜你們兩位要有
這方面的報告
對對對
就你初步很初步的沒關係
就講一下就好了
好那
接下來把時間給靜嘉
講一下你的CodeDiff
你快速兩三分鐘講一下你的成果就好了
好 那我直接
沒關係
我想說
那現在有三個小版本
然後十五之一 之二 跟之三
之一的話是我們那時候專題的
然後呢 現在就是我要去看說
我們把這個GBT的公式帶到
帶到UNET的部分
那現在有兩個
我把它分成兩個分支
第一個是將這個公式帶到Unit做訓練
然後第二個是我保留公式的引數
然後不保留公式
那這是什麼意思的話
這是什麼意思呢
就是這邊是GMP的一個公式
那它其實參照的因素主要有瑞士規模
然後正圓區跟長子放大的因子
那在15-12的版本呢
我把公式的係數把它拿掉
然後讓直接交給UNET做訓練
然後15-3是我直接把這個公式拿掉
就是沒有什麼誰稱誰的部分
就是我直接把它
直接把規模然後正圓句跟長者放大因子的這個引數
然後跟其他原本的通道
納到UNET去做訓練
然後呢
這邊直接看MAE
因為MAE最好看了
然後MAE的話呢
看15-12跟15-3
那你會發現15-3基本上除了5.0到5.5的地震
在其他的表現都會優於15-2
但是其實很酷的地方是
我目前還不知道為什麼15-2在這個5.0到5.5的地方
這個表現是比15-3還要來得好
這個是那個訓練級的部分
然後驗證級在這邊
可以先看一下
你說它表現比較好
怎麼看0.1443到變成0.08
這什麼意思
等一下這個忘了講
這個是UNET
這個是左邊這張圖是UNET
然後右邊是Diffusion Model
對
經過Diffusion Model之後
就是Final
最後的模型
所以Diffusion Model的效果蠻高的
對
以前看到好像不怎麼高
但是隻有
只有這個高
只有這個就是小於5.0
對大地震的話
還是差不多
所以15-3在M小於5的時候
比15-2好
基本上15-3只有5.0到5.5是差的
其他都是好的
對
那15-1是原來的
就是我們那種暑假的表現
很明顯優於15-1
對 那我覺得主要一個點就是
我覺得最主要的點是我們地震事件的數量變多了
因為像在大地震的部分
假如說這個5.5到6.0
我們那種暑假是利用55筆去做訓練
然後現在真的
那我覺得你15-1要讓他一樣的Data save
不然不能拼
對對對
所以我建議
這個地方讓它都是相同Data
因為這個蠻重要的
我們想要知道這三種方法到底
差多少
對差多少
所以你要讓它公平
好
但是老師現在有一個問題就是
那個你給的資料裡面有一些
其實它的步行是有損壞
或者是策戰不夠
因為有些其實是二三十年前的
然後我可以給你看一個失敗的案例
就是這個
可是我也不知道
我也不知道為什麼
這個是2018年1月的一個地震
然後它呢這樣在這邊
那你會發現它南部
就是從中部以下在的這個地方
就是震度分佈的是
就是很奇怪
然後那就是
Codex有跟我講說
說這個資料是他好像南部的資料整個都壞掉了
對 這個怪怪的
所以我有請
我剛剛有請Codei再根據
然後你都給的那一批資料
看一下是不是
因為我不確定是不是轉化的問題
因為那個資料是需要轉化的嘛
然後我還在現在再給他確認
那如果真的有資料不行的話
我會把它刪掉
對 所以我基本上目前就是這樣子
然後其實我們研究還有一個點是
我們有把它簡略的
就是我們那個JSON檔輸入的是正度
然後其實正度的資料有點太rough
但是我們公司是給PGA
對
所以其實應該要
我們的觀測資料應該要用PGA
會比較精準一點
對
那我們現在都是觀測資料用PGA轉正度
然後觀測資料直接用正度
然後那個計算的時候是用PGA轉正度
對所以其實兩個沒有很match
所以如果你這個
我覺得你先把前面那一張
15-1 2-2 3的那個比較
先讓它Data Say一樣
然後公平的比較完之後
我們可以考慮一下
能不能從那個觀測資料的時候就給PGA
不要給震度
對這個可能是下一步可以進行的
對好
好那大概就這樣
然後好我們等一下再說
好然後後面兩位同學我們再討論一下
好那這樣大家還有沒有什麼想要討論的
我覺得地震活動的部分,這邊四位同學也可以做一下,我覺得你們很有potential,然後做得也很快,也可以試試看,potential,潛力,潛能,非常的強,非常的high potential,I mean you have high potential to do the research,老師是in English mode.
我應該不會這一次中
我應該不會